what's the word son this week on thug
notes we gettin regicide Oh with Macbeth
by William Shakespeare after making a
[ __ ] out of their enemies the Kings
fresh generals Macbeth and Banquo hit up
three witches who start laying down some
cold prophets don't once you say one day
that's gonna rock the crown as king and
Bank walls blood also gonna be rolling
over oil doves one day Macbeth all
geeked up about being big baller but
it's woman Lady Macbeth be all like why
you wasting time playboy you best get
off your lazy white ass and take - so
lady McBee convinces McBee Z the shame
King Duncan while he catches some Z's
and lay the blame on his two
Chamberlain's while he passed out from
sipping too much drink Macbeth straight
trippin after doing the deed so his
woman steps up and puts the bloody knife
on the Chamberlain's as evidence what
some fool Macduff finds the Kings dead
body
Macbeth merge them Chamberlain so they
can't dodge the heat Oh paranoid that
somebody gonna ice them too Duncan's
sons Malcolm and Donalbain roll out of
town what dumb Punk's out of the way
Macbeth becomes the king since the
widgets that said bank walls blood gonna
be Kings one day Macbeth starts buggin
and says a couple of hoods to get Banquo
and his boy flee ons Banquo gets wreck
but flee on duds these fools later
Macbeth hollers at the three witches who
lay down some new prophecy first an
armored head tells him he best watch his
boy Macduff then a bloody child tell him
that nobody born of a woman can touch
him last a crowned child holding the
tree tells him he's silent till great
burning trees rolled up to the castle
word comes that Macduff don't roll out
to England so Macbeth gets ice cold and
kills his whole family damn
Lady Macbeth learns that his woman done
iced her south because she couldn't get
the blood off her hands at first
Macbeth ain't sweating the fact that
mouth was returned and got a swole Army
creeping up to the castle but then he
realizes the shields the army using are
from the same wood
which is luring them about Oh since
Macduff heard that his family and Castle
got smoked he wanna go toe-to-toe with
Macbeth on the battlefield Macbeth says
Macduff get off these nuts you were born
of a woman can't touch this turns out
Macduff's mama had a c-section when he
was born
something tough wife's that nasty smile
of his love and be answered this fool
then Malcolm takes back his throne and
Scotland got one less tyrant
this play right here is a classical
tragedy a battle let's righteous brother
who balls till he falls and it's an
unchecked ambition and lust for power
that makes them his own antagonist but
as Macbeth really the only one to blame
for having such a bootleg fate cuz on
the real it was Lady Macbeth who put a
fire under his ass to Merc the king and
you can't even blame no wenches for
feena's ambition and giving them a big
old head and scottish society got a ride
to beef to back then the man rap was you
ain't got a pair unless you grab all the
power you can no matter who you gotta
kill for so if you want to say Macbeth
got served cuz of all the people he
shanked you best recognize he was
getting mad props for butchering his
enemies at the begin another play in
fact some of the very 3rd say that
Macbeth ain't to blame at all but that
faints slinging them around like a
puppet making him act like a serious
fool just listen to how he talks about
life after his woman dies life's but a
walking shadow a poor player that struts
and frets his hour upon the stage and
then is heard no more it is a tale told
by an idiot full of sound and fury
signifying nothing
cuz if Macbeth ain't got no choice then
all this it's straight meaningless since
faint society and Macbeth bigger as head
land more pressure on them than it can
handle
Shakespeare dropping images of clothes
that don't fit good to show I display a
living way out of his death now he does
fill his title hang loose about him like
a giant's robe upon a dwarfish thief
new honours come upon him like our
strange garments cleaved not to their
mode but with the aid of use hey y'all
know how to make a player feel love man
so spread the love and tell your friends
peace
you
[Music]